one is still only its number one so long
last number two's alone two threes alone
falls alone home but I was alone we got
to get up into those double digits
before you're not alone eleven that's
the number you want to be oh well that's
that's good that is gold I can't be
stopped
thirteen that's a one hanging out with a
three nobody wants to be a ten that's a
one hanging out with a zero hey how you
doing pal hi new material how was your
that's fine I did this bit about
how a uppercase Q kind of looks like an
O with a coke problem but I think they
got it it's more of a visual in shields
have a thing about windshields wench
yeah why do they call them windshields
when I'm driving 75 miles per hour wind
is not my biggest concern and that's
something called a loogie shield how
about a miscellaneous auto parts flying
at you at 90 miles per hour shield you
never see a guy with bandages on his
head and you say hey what the hell
happened to you and he says wind I mean
that's funny right that's a bit that
could be something I think that yeah
like you should try it it's fine fines
when something is okay we say it's fine
when something's not okay you have to
pay a fine it's not fine pay the fine
pay the fine it's fine if it's fine
there is no fine not fine pay the fine
then it's fine fine fine fine thank you
thank you I actually have a bit about
that like the Heimlich maneuver ask for
it by name oh hold on I got something
better
sunglasses sunglasses yeah why are they
called sunglasses they block the Sun
they should be called auntie sunglasses
oh because they don't let the Sun in
they're anti glasses there's your
goddamn sunglasses that's funny right I
mean that's a good bit yeah yeah I think
you could try it you might want to tweet
it and see how it does on Twitter
Twitter online Internet why is it called
the Internet should be called the
Outernet I mean we're getting out there
we're connecting with people
they're called links good stuff right
here No maybe yeah yeah i Outernet
internet Outernet links it's maybe
there's something about the net aspect
that's why you waste so much time cuz
you're caught in the net a simple yes or
no will suffice if I needed a co-writer
I would have called puppet Larry David
sorry